hi welcome to a new project camp update in this
video you will see that we cut down a big bush
to plant a new garden we started to search for a
few locations for making platforms for a yoga deck
and we also went to a tree nursery
to search for some trees some bushes
some flowers to put down in the new
garden so i hope you enjoyed this video
i think this is good with the brush cutter okay
so we are going to cut this bush that looks quite
cool because it's on flowers in in the spring
but during the whole year it's not that cool
and we want to clear this area so we can
open up a bit more base camp maybe we have
a garden maybe we have a cinema place maybe
we have just square of the town where we can
meet we don't know yet but we it will open
a big space on in the kitchen so let's do it
uh
yes
hey
he's really eating up here well it's just an eater
it's really cute we have a lot of snails oh yeah
that's interesting before he gets stepped on up
so now we're going up the mountain here wait
up the mountain there because there's a really
beautiful place with some nice rocks and a good
view of the valley and it would be really nice to
use this place as well the bottom is a bit
hard and it cannot be grown or there's no
wood growing with this just a place of a nice
view this could use some joja decks so people
can also take a bit of relaxed time when they
are a bit done with the business of the camp
slowly yeah
yeah right
yeah but this is definitely definitely a cool
cool possibility we did not even walk here
maybe kind of nice just a swinging chair
could also be enough here yeah a giant swing
that sounds nice all right hey mick yeah i think
this could be a really nice place because you look
at the other surrounding rocks of the land and
there's a nice ancient looking rock here in front
yeah it's surrounded by some nice
trees and a few of the mountains there
yeah i'm really around this area where you can
really have a panoramic view yeah and you think
you were thinking so smaller platforms three by
three this was an initial thought also to give
a bit of if different people want to what have
their space they don't all need to be together
yeah good view to the east yeah sunrise
yeah yesterday it was really beautiful
there was all fog in the valley and you
saw the mountains there sticking out
the idea is now to do several places so when
people want to be a bit alone and do their own
thing then there also is place for several people
doing this at the same time without interfering
each other yeah because this makes really a
logical part yep so actually if people also
want to walk so then you would put it a bit more
in front so you can walk more easily you can just
we found a really nice old madronja it's a native
tree for this area and the wood seems to be really
good for making nice stuff with like olive wood
or high quality wood so let's see what's in there
oh this i don't want to kill you oh yeah
it this tree is bur it's more bush the
bush is burned so we're not sure if the
wood's still good but let's have a look
it's a bit dry i think it still looks good it's
a bit burnt on the outside and the inside is
really dry but maybe if you take a bigger stem
it can be still can still be used for something
it's nice it's really small rings which means
it's a slow growing tree it's also pretty hard
but here i also really like the eclipse
you do yeah yeah from here from this point
yeah i think it's very beautiful
don't relate to them emotionally
with uh yeah yeah yeah with this management
that like yeah just the way they have been
over planted yeah yeah the madronia can
use some more light to grow a bit bigger
why do people plant as like so many eucalyptus
trees like especially when they are burned like
hell yeah i mean it's paper industry that's
really they all sell to the paper industry
paper industry portugal cleaning the ass of europe
what do you mean like the all the paper
the paperwood comes from toilet paper
so we're using all that eucalyptus
trees here for toilet paper
cellulose actually yeah yeah
fast growing trees uh easy i mean a
lot of government support for that
so it's really yeah easy money easy
money yeah in principle that's already
a shitty principle like of monocultures
of eucalyptus but the big problem is that
people plant them and like here around
for example most of the lands are like
abandoned so the eucalyptus obviously grow
like too much close together so in terms of
fire prevention which is already very poor with
the monoculture when it's an abandoned field of
monoculture then it's just it's like a lightning
match or something yeah doomed to to feel yeah
how it curves and like the branches like here
shall we go to a third place yeah let's do it
so we were thinking we went to this place a third
option for a deck or another option for a deck
and then we were really discussing ah wait
wouldn't it be great if we go down and find
this very different kind of environment
to put it maybe more closer to the water
and then we got really excited so we're gonna go
down and see if we can find a nice place there
it may be easy to give them all the
same shape yep so it's just like yeah
so we just finished the tour
around the places to find the
yoga decks and now this piece will become
a garden soon and for that we need to go
to the tree nursery and get some bushes
some trees and make it beautiful again
people are always [ __ ] on this
car because it's the old lady
and it's kind of special first gear is
difficult second gear is difficult you can't
really see the velocity you're
going but it goes up the mountain
like now for example i'm doing the third
now i don't know i don't know it seems quite
complex now to change the gearbox yeah i think so
but there is this super cool guys nearby
and they will fix a few parts of the gears
Good morning
Where are you going? Are you going out?
We go to get trees and bushes
And plants
To make that more beautiful
You are going to plant. Isn`t it?
Now it is the time to do it.
In a bit i will drop by and drink a tea with you.
Come. come, come there to drink a tea with us.
Just if you would be there.
We will be there. We just go to pick them up. We will be back before 1.
See you later Fernanda! Come by.
We will have lunch here.
Will you have lunch here? Okay good. See you later.
And your husband, when is he coming back?
Today.
Then you need to get ready
Do I need to get ready?
You need to get ready. There have been many days
Well prepared, exactly. Isn´t it?
Of course
A good welcome
See you later. Have a good day!
this is a full neighbor. neighbour-tour
a bit lacking in confidence
so we just arrived to the tree shop this is
the sign that we just arrived to the shop
and we will get some trees some bushes
some flowers just to expand the garden
some of the plants last year
didn't survive to winter like
teas like lemongrass tea and i hope i can find
it here so we can put it back into the soil again
so we are back from the shop we got some
very nice bushes and one single tree
this is for me a tree that i would not know how to
say the name in english but it symbolizes spring
because it's the first fruit of spring which is
in portuguese called neshpara a yellow fruit like
this sized we have some aromatics and we have a
lot of good smelling flowers and plants and bushes
it's really not enough for the whole garden that
we want to plant but parallel to this we also have
some seedlings that are still growing and we will
see what else will be to complement the garden
we are taking out some
bushes and sometimes it might
seem that they are invasive species or
creating a lot of damage but actually
what they do is that they are nourishing
a lot the soil and this soil is like
super fluffy super nutritious so these plants
will actually have a very good start for them
what are you eating there
communities
oh
uh
okay
this was the lemongrass that died last year
so let's see if this survives this winter
because it was too cold yes
too cold
one two three five six
name
yeah that was it for this video
we now reached 100 000 subscribers
thank you guys for supporting we actually
reached this one week ago but you see this one
week later because our patrons if you support
there you can see the video one week ahead
and then you would have this news on time
anyway thanks for watching see you the next time